passage premiered in January and it's on
Monday nights at 9:00 Eastern Time
and it is hugely popular starring in
part this man
mark-paul Gosselaar good to see you sir
you bet so let's get into it you or
gamely putting on our Callaway corner
yeah that's the first time I've had a
club in my hand for probably over a year
now because you have multiple shoulder
surgeries so I had shoulder surgery
after we filmed pitch
you played a catcher or hide a catcher
in 2016 I had left shoulder surgery and
now just had right shoulder surgery at
the beginning of this year so did pitch
playing a catcher and it's not gonna say
it didn't Ken throwing did that lead to
your shoulders I'm right-handed okay but
would really sort of made the situation
worse was the constant batting and the
torque from batting and there was a
specific incident that happened on set
that might have popped a tendon can we
can we bring that up what do we got I
mean what happened on set I it was bad
before so this was just like I seen on
the on the cake there was a there's no
ohsho suit or anything there was no no
no workers comp and I had slid into the
dugout and my elbow caught the ground
and I just kind of popped it up but it
was bad before then it was I was on my
way to the table before then and this
made it just a little more worse so so
you did your own stunts we do it I did
all my I could tell you in the pilot
there was only one point where it wasn't
me mm-hm but for the most part
throughout that run that show was all me
and and in the passage those that's I
mean there's a there's a really big
stunt episode coming up this week and
it's all me it's it's when I was working
with a bum right shoulder during the
filming so did anything happen in the
passage that caused you to go under the
knife here as well no I actually we
started filming in August and in May I
had an injury from jujitsu that I needed
to have an MRI done it was it was
basically they said I needed surgery
back in May but because we were filming
I couldn't you know Jitsu so that's what
you do and you're doing - parrots
yeah so you could kick somebody's ass is
what you're saying no no why would you
say that well I have to say that right
cuz then if you if you say you can't
kick anybody's ass and no we're not
gonna ask you to kick their ass right
but if you say you can kick people's ass
and you're gonna get people coming up to
yo you can kick my ass let's let's see
you get my so when let me impart to get
fine I walk around saying I can kick
people's ass right then you're gonna get
people then it's a challenging you and
it's on right so then I apologize in
advance if I am besmirching when you are
healthy yes and you're playing golf
do you also lie about your handicap of
course are you kidding me charity golf
event where you your actual handicap is
which are playing with you get struck I
mean come on rich I know and you want to
pop I understand that you want to do
that but you can't come out and say
you're 12 and you're 12 and ECAP and
then start bird iing right off the bat
you can't do that you can't I'm sorry I
met you can I now I understand yeah you
can't just walk through the front door
you wanted you want to you want to sneak
around listen listen whatever you have
to do to win I mean you know you know
how it is I sports world I do like them
whatever you have to do to win I'm not
above it you've got gene you ain't
trying see that's your philosophy if you
ain't cheating you ain't trying but it's
not cheating right right you're just
kind of manipulating your you're finding
loopholes exactly these are all
euphemisms no the Vita yeah that's a
that's pretty strong that's a strong
word I was fortunate enough to play in
the pro-am last week here is that now
that you have to give you a legitimate
handicap which was 18 I think because
you know I but I don't I don't you play
as an 18 though yeah I did I did I did
you know cuz you know around hole 12 I'm
like man it's you know I'm it's tough
getting around you know I mean just
trying to get your body through it's
tough walking the course yeah you know I
mean work that's I'm being very honest
here okay and I would follow up a
birdy net eagle with a lost ball sure so
when I did that I'm like kind of glad
I'm I'm my true self but you at least
admit that you have to play to your
handicap when you do something like that
when you're playing that event of course
but if you're playing like a charity
event for good come on it's for charity
all right mark-paul Gosselaar who is
admitted three things there we got to
the best thing in his bag is his pencil
there's eraser right here on the
Richards joke so you do in the passage
you must have a bunch of people that are
focusing on the details of your show to
make sure that you are doing this the
right way correct you're looking at him
that's you that's so you read the books
and you're locked locked in your read
all the books okay I went through
tactical training which was really cool
didn't need to go through the tactical
training for the character but I
convinced the production that my
character would be because he was
Special Forces and he worked for the FBI
is like he needs to go through tactical
training so I trained with the guy who
trained John wick because I'm like that
guy would know some things and and
trained yeah did the weapon weapons
training with the guy who trained John
wick so you used yours again for all
finding loopholes rich this is life this
is how you make it
auditioning for John wick force I'm
gonna use this in the in the future how
long did it take you to get through the
800 pages is it 800 pages because on my
iPad I bumped up the 5000 a
thousand-page book right I got through
pretty quick because it's it's a it's a
page-turner
he leaves much like our show we leave
every episode with you wanting more sure
so I got through it pretty quick I
actually got through all three books and
and probably three weeks
damn but again I wasn't I wasn't being a
very good husband I wasn't being a very
good father kids were hungry and they
didn't go to school that week that's odd
okay they just okay because I was
working I was also to work passage
in the past don't make yourself a
sandwich yeah and the cast is great
Henry and Cusick who fans from lost know
all about yeah Emmanuel shrieky who's
been here she is a delightful
she plays my ex-wife right and we find
out why she became my ex in the next
episode okay I took an incident that
happened between us I don't want to
spoil anything for those who may not
already know and when we had we had a
manual here and she's so nice she is
just so nice that Mike Dell too far
audio executive yeah came up with an
idea you want to tell mark Paul what you
what your idea was of him a helicopter
ride to Catalina for dinner he wanted to
offer up not just to her but to any you
know he thinks it's a great first date
idea to take somebody on a helicopter
ride to Catalina and she loved it and
these guys both you know what do you
think of that idea yeah I don't know
it's a lot it's pretty aggressive it's
an aggressive play it is aggressive I
mean I'm gonna take out the pretty
aggressive it is aggressive it's all the
egress its aggressive in it there's no
out right there is no there is no out
like how do you get out of that you know
I'm in a helicopter with you another no
amount of Catalina which is an island I
can't run so it's it's like there's too
many exactly if you're just having a
straight dinner as a first day sure and
you can check your watch conversations
awkward you got it you can go you can go
now it's like let's fire up the thing
cuz I got to get off this island it's
like you've bet your your even prison
them you're you're right so Emmanuel was
just like what a great idea
say that yes so she suck I think that's
great like you know if you she was just
kidding me just put it out she liked the
idea so you wanna blindfold me and get
me on a helicopter sounds amazing I know
she's too nice she is and yeah I yeah I
think you're taking advantage of people
are too nice with the helicopter thing
what's wrong with just going out for
coffee or going out for a nice little
dinner actually when you step it up like
that it is a little aggressive have you
ever actually done that or that's just
in that you have with an idea that makes
it even more creepy you still work
mark-paul Gosselaar here on the Rich
Eisen show can you can you hit the drop
for celebrity true or false please here
for mark-paul Gosselaar please thank you
[Music]
we have some some topics and some
credits that you have been given online
and there's some other stories that
we've read in articles we just want to
know if it's true or false
my first up first on-screen credit was
highway to heaven when you were 12 years
old is that a true story it could be a
true story
and I got to shoot an Uzi 12 years old
that does not sound like it's an Uzi is
on the highway to heaven I
it was a inflaming the difference is how
dark this one gets to it I was a child
of a Nazi family and and we were
shooting a Susie that I accidentally
killed my father with and the highway to
heaven highway to heaven yeah that's
about all I remember that is the
strangest episode of highway to right
yeah
did you so Michael and did you meet him
and no I briefly met him we're talking
legend yeah of course and I remember him
being super nice then too that's cool
next one during the Saved by the Bell
years you would have to have your hair
dyed every two weeks is that that is
absolutely true
I'm surprised I still have hair now why
I mean it wasn't real what do you have
to have your hair dyed every because I
went in
we had over dyed my hair for the
audition process and they liked that
look and so we had to keep that look for
the rest of the five-year run my hair is
this color this is this is mean are you
serious my mother's Indonesian my father
is Dutch so I had blondish hair when I
was young right and my mom would always
put son-in in my hair remember that
stuff that chemical supposed to give you
blond highlights you're supposed to go
spray it in your hair then go play
outside right while it's being processed
like 70s that's not on the highway to
heaven either yeah no and so that yeah
for the for the look of Zack Morris if
it had to be blonde is it true your mom
drove you to the set every day that a
chant is true yeah that is true no
kidding yeah she was a set mom this set
mom yeah how many did everyone have a
set everybody had a set mom no kid and
they became our managers which is what
happens in all the way another one for
you you were accepted to Yale but didn't
attend because of Saved by the Bell but
college years is that true
we false that is false that's absolutely
I even have an SAT score that you had
are you sure you're not mixing the
character because I think the character
are you serious am i reading what's
happened is I think Zack Morris was
accepted I mean I'm sure somebody the
audience can figure that one out but I
so you did not get a 1502 on your entry
that Zack Morris okay we did some
sleuthing oh my gosh
last one for you you won something
called the category 5 4 5 sprint
championship event at the Encino Village
area that's absolutely true
I actually if anybody knows anything
about cycling but I you start off as a
cat5 and I moved up to a cat 2 which is
pretty much pro cat 1/2 is pro or they
race with the pros in less than two
years so I I was actually really good at
cycling did you ever think of like
really getting him into it now such tool
by the time I got into cycling it was
right around the time I was on my PD
blue so I was 30 when I got into it and
I all I wanted to do was make it to the
Masters so that I could race with guys
my age right which masters I think at
that point was 35 years old how was it
on my PD blue the best right the best
working with Dennis Franz and then being
protected by Steven Bochco
what I mean him protected how do you
protect you because he's one of my
favorite people of all time right and
and that's why when you meet this guy
you you realize that you're in a safe
environment he creates an environment
that allows you to be creative but he
also makes you feel like he's got it
under control
you just do your thing I've got the rest
worked out and so that just creates an
environment where you feel safe you know
you're getting great material to make
you look really good
honestly it was like one of the best
projects I've ever been a part of Dennis
Franz Dennis Franz I mean here's a guy
that when I got on the shows then their
ninth season we ended up doing 12
seasons but he had been nominated nine
times for an Emmy I think he won four
times he still had the the fire the
desire
every day to show up to work and and and
get the job done I mean he was he was
one of the most genuine loving
supportive actors you could ever work
with people you could have worth I love
that and is it true you you said the
last line in the history of the series
did I really that's what that's what I
believe is right that's the other
celebrity true or false question where
they is that is that true I'll take that
you know I think it's an ingenious show
obviously that lasted for so long for
such a good for such a good reason and
obviously you were part of that too
thanks for coming on man thanks for
having me any time any time would come
back when you're you're feeling good
let's let's go play some golf I would
love to you sure you want to play
anything out now you know I do not trust
on my bag I do not trust you as far as I
could throw you sir but I'm still
willing to go out there play with us
Callaway balls check out yeah please by
the way take some I'll take some you
can't you are more than welcome to do
that
you I know you wanted to give the bags
you know what they kept folks at
Callaway sent us five golf bags just
those are tour bags by the back yeah no
somewhat the Rich Eisen show logo on it
those are not yours to keep
but there are some golf balls that were
much we're willing to give you you want
a pot or take a putter take a putter
take a part of mark-paul Gosselaar sauna
it's on I don't know it's on take its on
someone it's on someone I don't know
what's on that's not me the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience